I mentioned this last night it's been
brought to our attention that a talk
show in China has completely ripped off
our show's opening sequence this is this
is thank you this the show this is all
real what I'm telling you we didn't make
this up the show is called da Peng and
you know a lot of people say they're
being ripped off and then you look at it
you think I don't know maybe maybe not
check this out this is a side-by-side
comparison of our shows opening and da
peng's show opening and as I said before
this is absolutely real check it out
[Music]
that's crazy they just basically they
took our opening and they're just using
it without our permission and to make
matters worse it's a very weird show you
think this show is weird
check out there showing again this is
completely hundred percent real check it
out yeah sure what's all about do you
know what he's gonna tell Lila for what
huh ha yeah you're late what wait what
mean I heard about cake well well what
do that tonight was yeah
well guess what I was thinking about
this and I talked about last night now
I'm angry for years China's been ripping
off America with cheap knock-offs right
well I want to speak to China right now
China if you're gonna rip off my show
I'm gonna rip off your show let's see
how you like it but it stings doesn't it
yeah check this out
[Applause]
exploding rickshaw hey and how about
Asian guys rubbing each other on my show
do you watch him on the pillow poison
Hey
and meet my sexy co-host
hey let's see what the general thinks
[Applause]
we got a great show tonight for you
ladies and gentlemen a pencil
[Applause]
I already think they've improved her
show I think it's nice